é incrível estar aqui com vocês e eu
estou muito feliz por ser um palco muito
próxima das pessoas não é de que isso é
uma grande diferença do detex bom ganhou
seu carrinho de bebê ea dois anos atrás
eu estava nesse outro tex e eu entrei
vão assim bom se eu tivesse 15 segundos
em vez de 15 minutos para deixar a
mensagem essa mensagem seria que existe
muita coisa boa acontecendo canção
brasileira
eu estava cansado porque eu falei isso
foi muito mais nada do que eu tive mas
eu estava muito cansado de ver escolas
que não era escolas noticiário escolas
que não há escolas com os motoristas de
táxis costa na escolas como pauta das
conversas de educação eu tinha certeza e
não conhecemos eu tinha certeza que
tinha muita coisa boa acontecendo no
brasil e hoje eu venho aqui dois anos
depois com uma mensagem diferente se
tivesse os mesmos 15 segundos hoje e
dizer que existem pontos luminosos não
cansam brasil sim são muitos como a
casinha amarela mas a gente tem uma
responsabilidade muito grande pra fazer
com que não existam escolas ou escolas e
que nenhuma criança não tenha
oportunidade de ter uma educação de
qualidade em que transformações sociais
sejam feitas a partir do cação e
responsabilidade é toda nossa
eu queria hackear um pouco a plataforma
do tex e fazer um convite pra vocês sei
só com um
a idéia é o seguinte essa menina com
esse logo em seguida da viagem que eu
fiz o brasil eu vou contar um pouco
depois acham karina milton iam me
inspirou muito porque ela é uma
jornalista ambiental uma ativista e ela
fez um deck ribeirão preto chamado
intuição como ponto de partida e ela
segue muito as instituições dela e
aceitar o chamado
e vai pra luta e faz acontecer as coisas
que ela acreditando é um dia estava numa
no exercício no meio da floresta
carregando uma cadeira olhando para
baixo subir no morro da viúva formiga
pegue uma folha é a nossa gente é igual
né está na mesma situação aqui em pouco
depois ela teve uma imagem de uma
floresta pegando fogo quando estava em
cima já refletindo e a entender que
aquilo era chamado para a amazônia
então ela foi para a amazônia e foi
trabalhar no greenpeace eto'o muito para
as devastações da amazônia pararam de
acontecer e ao tek dela mais do que isso
e vale a pena ver a história mas só fez
um exercício muito interessante que não
recebeu um paninho espanha uma venda
eu quero que vocês se vendas em e
fechassem os olhos e seguissem eu vou
fazer um metro até jackie pede dentro
pede seguir um pouco o que é karina vai
falar o que ela faz melhor que eu
respiro fundo
coloque as mãos no coração sinta qual é
o próximo sonho que você quer realizar
aquele sonho de sempre calou fundo na
sua alma
estamos em um lugar segundo
aqui não existe medo aqui não existem
fãs
estamos no reino das femininas
idade
veja se realizando este sonho sintam com
seus sentidos o que você vê como ele é
é o cheiro que você sente
você toca em algo no que sinta o top
agora veja se ao lado das pessoas que
você mais ama
compartilhando as novidades desta regras
assim que vc quis todo o conte para elas
o que você fez
faça um brinde
com menores
sinta o gosto da bebida que está no foto
um céu sol da sua celebração
parabéns você conseguiu
qual é o tamanho da sua felicidade neste
ano
sinta essa felicidade
ouvir a intuição o coração
vale a pena
acredite em seus sonhos
os medos dos outros
não são os seus
que sua humanidade
através da escuta interna o seu coração
da sua intuição ou de sua comunidade
onde quer que você esteja nessa vida
op
vocês podem tirar venda
eu vivo esse trecho do tédio da karina
dos meus dias desde 2013 quando eu
peguei
resolvi sair do emprego colocar uma
mochila nas costas só pra minha mãe que
eu ia sair de casa e ficar cinco meses
randy ônibus no brasil para conhecer
iniciativas que estão fazendo a
diferença na educação e realidades
brasileiras as pessoas do país eo tema
intuição pegar um avião fetam pará e fui
descendo por 58 cidades meio sem saber o
que encontrará em de um jeito muito
despretensioso e eu conheci muitas
histórias e conheça histórias de pessoas
como essa diretora que a gente acabou de
ver conhecer a história de pessoas que
nas primeiras entrar na universidade de
toda a comunidade
histórias de garotos que já tinham
desistido de estudar e voltaram para a
faculdade por causa de alguma
oportunidade e fizeram outras garotas
como eles também entrar em escolas que
dava liberdade para as crianças
escolas que mostrar outras opções
projetos huggies pessoas que estarão
muito mas hoje eu não vou contar tanto
edições pode conversar disso no rap hour
porque hoje eu quero contar muito de
algumas coisas que aprendi nos últimos
anos que trazem essa questão da nossa
responsabilidade
a primeira delas é um senso de urgência
na educação que é isso mesmo muita coisa
boa acontecendo a gente ainda precisa
fazer muito
esses números são verdadeiros e são
atualizados hoje dia 27 de fevereiro de
2006 3.8 milhões de crianças e jovens
estão fora da escola e não por uma
questão de metodologia de crença em
pedagogia por falta de acesso 25% dos
jovens não conseguem acabar o
fundamental 2
então é muito urgente quench bote mão na
massa discutir nossa intuição perder
nossos medos e juntos a gente trabalha
por uma educação de qualidade
um exemplo prático e objetivo que eu
queria trazer aqui
a esac muito conhecem já que é uma ong
que trabalha onde se promove a liderança
a partir de intercâmbios culturais
esquento jovens aqueles foram eleitos no
ano passado eles tinham uma missão e são
eleitos com alguns objetivos eles têm um
ano para aplicar o que eles acreditam
trabalham muito e têm senso de urgência
de que eles precisam trabalhar muito e
trabalhar juntos e deram uma rede de 3
mil membros que faz em 8 mil
intercâmbios com ou sem crise porque
tenha senso de urgência precisa ter isso
na hora do carro tanto na sala de aula
quanto em projetos quanto nosso dia a
dia
outra coisa que é fundamental que eu
aprendi nos últimos anos a empate ano
tanta empatia com os seus parceiros do
projeto com o seu principal e com
diferente muita falta muita gente a
educação em muita gente não concordo
100% com que eles dizem
mas eu paro e tento sem pensar com o
cenário que essa pessoa vive porque ele
só tem esse posicionamento dizendo essas
coisas e assim a gente consegue
estabelecer um diálogo de verdade a
gente consegue juntos ignorar algumas
diferenças de focar nas nossas
semelhanças para melhorar a educação no
brasil
em vez de ficar com várias brigas porque
o pessoal gente como falei antes isso na
sala de aula é muito importante eu dou
aula e acho que uma das coisas mais que
mais mexem comigo e com os garotos e
garotas que trabalham comigo nesse curso
é tá presente de verdade para eles é
olhar no olho e eu escutar o que eles
têm dizê lo e eles me escutam o que eu
tenho a dizer a gente construir coisas
juntos porque a gente tá lá de verdade
um pro outro com intenções semelhantes
estes são princípios de comunicação não
violenta que também podem ser aplicados
em vários lugares e agora o que eu mais
uma das coisas mais importantes do meu
desejo nada de aprendizado do caí no
brasil foi no passado quando entrou em
contato com estudo do instituto
inspirarem chama dores dele
de aprender com impacto em educação e
empreender
ela tinha hoje empreender tomar risco
então eu quero que você escutar assim
isso não como a eu vou abrir um negócio
não você pode empreender na sua vida
pessoal
quando fiz uma viagem e empreende eu
tomei um risco e não sabe o que
aconteceu e eles contam sobre a jornada
de aprendizagem do empreendedor de
impacto em educação o que ele vai
encontrar em cada etapa e com quem pode
contar
mas o que mais me ensinou esse estudo
foi o que tinha na mochila do
empreendedor de impacto em educação
a primeira coisa era um conhecimento
grande em educação
se você vai querer melhorar a educação
você tem que entender de educação
augustin
as pessoas que fizeram esse coworking
entendem de economia colaborativa de
trabalho colaborativo e de espaços de
encontro
senão nem assim ele seria totalmente
diferente
segunda coisa é uma opinião mais uma
leitura pessoal que é qual o impacto que
você quer causar no mundo
eu acredito que existem três caminhos de
impacto que a gente pode causar no mundo
você pode ter escala como a geek que é
uma plataforma de ensino
profissionalizado que ajudou cinco
milhões de jovens brasileiros a irem bem
no enem
você pode ter um impacto altíssimo em
poucas pessoas como eu caí no brasil que
hoje é uma consultoria de educação e
inovação que tem poucos clientes
parceiros e trabalha muito bem com eles
para conseguir a excelência do projeto
que realmente transforma em vidas e
traga educação com significado
você pode no meio do caminho que é pra
mim o mais desafiador que é conseguir
ficar ali consegui impacto que a eset
faz é não existe caminho certo e ao
errado são questões que a gente toma é
importante firmar o pé nas lesões porque
só assim você consegue saber qual o
caminho a seguir
por que você quer estar lá e você
trabalhar no caminho de gerar impacto
você nunca conseguirá atingir seu
objetivo
em um deste caminho claro é muito
importante
e o terceiro é um conhecimento do
negócio tanto na sua vida pessoal quanto
na sua carreira
ser sustentável é fundamental e tem um
conhecimento que o empreendimento um
negócio que você de vez em quando vai
ter que fazer burocracia e coisas chatas
o planejamento estratégicos
o pensar na sustentabilidade e pra isso
tem que emitir nota fiscal
é chato pra caramba eu não tenho nenhuma
paciência para fazer isso mas quando eu
levei essa porrada na cara de que se eu
quisesse empreender com o impacto e
tecnologia para o negócio e comecei a
fazer cair no brasil começou a crescer
muito porque aumenta muito a potência
agora tão importante quanto tudo isso é
uma coisa que tem embaixo da cadeira de
vocês
embaixo da casa de vocês têm um papel
jf daí se possa falar palavrão aqui em
cima do palco mas dias fucking do its
mais importante que pensar em contrato
um planejamento estratégico com o
impacto urgência responsabilidade é meu
vai lá e faz
sai daqui e amanhã hoje à noite já
começa a botar a mão na massa porque se
a gente ficar tão preocupado com tudo
isso a gente tem que ter essas coisas em
mente e gui anos nossos caminhos mas
negócio a gente pegar vai lá e faz
acontecer porque não podem ter quatro
milhões de jovens fora da escola e bull
isso é inaceitável é só trabalhando
muito juntos e com uma vontade uma garra
e entender esse propósito e aceitar o
chamado que a gente vai ter uma educação
de qualidade em educação para todos a
gente vai reduzir as desigualdades
sociais são tantas no brasil em che vai
evitar que escolas não sejam escolas
escola tem ser divertido espero que
escolas ou seja escolas no sentido de
ficar fingindo que está doente para ir à
escola não ir à escola tipo as escolas
têm sido incríveis e mágicas com certeza
e agente é responsável por fazer isso
acontecendo e contem comigo nessa é
espero que eu possa ajudar a todos vocês
nas jornadas e aqui os meus contatos no
facebook é caiu de bico e muito obrigado
mesmo para essa oportunidade incrível ea
gente fala gente
valeu